hey everyone i'm abby sharp let's shoot
a vlog
winter edition
[Music]
so you know what they say baby it's cold
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
outside while i am not
ready for christmas that's gonna be a
whole other video if you guys want so
leave me a comment below if you do
but i do need to
winterize my life and i know my southern
american friends and followers are like
winter
what's that
winter is like a mood here in canada
it's actually more than a mood it's like
it's a way of life
and
by no choice of our own but i thought if
i maybe took you guys along with me i
could make the whole preparation phase a
little more fun and a little less of a
chore so that i could make wearing a
parka more glam
and less glum is glam a word say
when you think about the word glum it's
weird
it's a weird word glum i'm not feeling
it anyways let's do this
but first let me tell you about my
sponsor squarespace so i remember when i
started abby's kitchen getting the
website going seemed like the biggest
hurdle i just didn't even know where to
start but when i'm coaching new bloggers
now they often feel so encouraged that
services like squarespace make it so
much more intuitive and easy so if
you're not in the know squarespace is an
all-in-one platform for any website blog
or online store there are so many
amazing features between blogging and
commenting social media and e-commerce
extensions for those who sell products
online i've been blown away just by how
easy and simple they pull together all
of the hard parts of getting a business
or passion project off the ground so
that you can really just focus on what
you do best so if you're interested in
getting started you can check out
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com
abby sharp to get 10 off of your first
purchase of a website or domain all
right it is the weekend and i thought
we'd do some pancakes to celebrate uh
but not just any pancakes because we are
balls deep in pumpkin spice season can
you say oh my gourd so we're gonna do
some pumpkin spice protein pancakes this
is a classic
abby's kitchen staple and i'm gonna
leave the link below to the recipe it's
a favorite around here and i think it's
gonna be really good kids are gonna love
it let's do it
oats
gonna make our own oat flour
cottage cheese all right let's get some
eggs
it is my biggest fear to put my hand in
a blender or
a food processor while
it's turned off
but
it's still plugged in because one time i
did that with an immersion blender and i
almost had to go to the er because i
thought i took my fingers off now you
can also do this with just straight up
egg whites if you want more protein and
a little less fat but i'm going to make
sure the kids are going to eat these as
well so we're going to do the whole egg
and a banana pumpkin pie spice
[Music]
man
these are buttes
[Music]
guys this is so good and with the maple
syrup
guys
i went shopping
[Music]
the season is changing and i just felt
like i needed a refresh and also i know
you guys like the halls so of course
this is just my excuse to buy more
clothes so shall we do a try on we shall
check this out
she cozy
so soft i like never want to take this
off and actually i have this from last
year and it's like one of my favorite
sweaters so i got it in this kind of
what is this like
moss sage green love
this
guys i'm living for the cashmere i only
want to wear cashmere this fall and
winter because
if i'm going to be stuck
inside with two kids in another kind of
covered lockdown situation i better be
effing
comfy this is kind of cute
now the only thing i don't like about it
is that they make these shirts so damn
short like i know they're meant to be
tucked in but i got a long torso and it
is annoying as
f
love me a sweater dress that is so comfy
i love long sleeve dresses because in
the winter fall if it's not cozy
i'm not gonna wear it so today i've
decided we have got to do some winter
gear organizing
and it is like one of my least favorite
things to do but she's gotta get done
because when the winter hits it hits
hard and i need to make sure that i've
got everything that the kids need and i
feel prepared
[Music]
i am exhausted just from bringing all of
these all of this gear into one place
and i haven't even started organizing so
i think my game plan here is to do
one bag for donations one bag or bin for
things that i'm keeping but don't yet
fit o yet but e has outgrown and then
anything that we're going to actively be
using this winter i'm going to try to
put and organize
in the closet wish me luck and i am so
jealous of all you floridians and you
californians californians is that a word
but anyways and anyone else in a hot
climate who does not have to do this
every single year
[Music]
these are so cute
we haven't even worn these yet but
they're so so cute
oh
sort through
the kiddos shoes to see what's going to
fit
oh look how cute this is
still a bit too big but
soon enough
these were favorites
look at these cute little
are these vans no they're disney zara so
cute
that's probably gonna be fitting these
vans
rough shape yes
but
what's not in rough shape when you are a
newly walking
infant so yeah these are super cute and
those will fit soon okay so in addition
to
my own haul i just got delivery of a few
things for the kids
and i was like of course you're gonna
want to see these because kids clothes
are so cute and not just little girl
clothes fyi for those of you who think
that oh no there's nothing sweeter
than a little bitty button-up
shirt
and like little trousers
sweet little fleece patagonia
sweaters i feel like i need one should i
get one to match the boys i feel like i
should i would totally wear this and
it's like a gender-neutral color
obviously because there's no such thing
as boy clothes and girl clothes
in this house some little slush pants
oh god they're cute okay so i got
everything matched
because i can't just buy one of anything
these days
so these ones are for e big ticket item
i got you a coat basically i just buy
the same thing year after year i just
get a size up love it
so
sweet i feel like we're getting ready
there snow get at me morning so it is
super rainy and gross outside and like
really dark
and dreary and i just dropped off e at
school
so i thought we would do some soup to
enjoy probably for dinner but knowing me
and it's really good and it's sitting
here i'm also gonna have for lunch so
we're gonna do my gochujang carrot and
parsnip soup from abby's kitchen kind of
a take on it i don't have coconut milk
which i normally put in there but it's
just going to be an extra spicy addition
because the coconut milk really does
help to mellow it out but if you haven't
explored gochujang yet it is one of my
favorite condiments it's a korean sweet
and spicy chili paste and adds so much
flavor to so many recipes i use it in a
ton of abby's kitchen recipes so yeah
let's make some soup
okay so while that's
simmering away i am preparing for a
photo shoot tomorrow and trying to get
all of my wintry clothes out for that
and then organize the clothes for the
kit so i'll show you what i've got so
far okay so we've got a beautiful little
jacket look
and a very cool like boho
fall 70s look i love this so this is
what the boys are gonna wear they've got
matching shirts like that got some nice
sweater action
this beautiful jacket this is a canadian
designer very excited to wear that
little beautiful dress and i think the
boys are going to wear their
black for that and look how cute these
shirts are snacks aren't live
unfortunately because you guys know i
don't show my kids face
you will not see the cute slogans but
you will see the cute backs of their
heads lots of goodies lots of goodies
that i'm excited about and obviously
sweater life is my kind of life
all right now we blend
i'm making such a mess oh my goodness
so good
and this is when i would add in the
coconut milk if i had it but i don't so
i think a nice little swirl of yogurt
for serving will do the trick
[Music]
all right
she's thick what are you thinking here
he's saddened i mean i like a thick soup
but normally this recipe has a whole can
of coconut milk in it so it is a thinner
soup
but i also secretly like a thick soup so
if you don't and you don't have coconut
milk also you can just throw in some
more stock basically just to thin it out
to taste
stoop as rachel ray would say so we have
a photo shoot today and it's always
really fun to do the photo shoots but
also when you have to
have two kids looking okay and not
screaming and crying and also
positioning them in such a ways to
conceal their identity while also trying
to look good and pose and make sure that
the clothing you're sitting a perfect
way and blah blah blah it is
physically and
kind of mentally
exhausting so i'm trying to get myself
amped up and psyched for
two hours of complete chaos all i can do
is hope that the photos look good by the
end of this photos at the end of a crazy
day are like the loot bag
for adults am i right
adult loot bag
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
guys
i am ready for
a sh
store but like
an actual one because i live in canada
and that's how we get here but i feel
like i'm ready
for winter now like i've got i got the
cozy clothes i got the cozy food i got
the cozy photo evidence of me in said
cozy clothes and eating said cozy food
what more could an influencer want right
i hope you guys had a fun time coming
along with me on this one uh thank you
again to squarespace for sponsoring and
of course if you like this style of like
bts kind of content definitely leave me
a comment below let me know that you
love it give it the thumbs up subscribe
to the channel
and i'll see you next time on abby's
kitchen bye
you